we are counting down a Broadway's
biggest night the 76th annual Tony
Awards ain't no mo has six nominations
including for best play now this show is
a raw satirical comedy starring and
written by Jordan e Cooper he became the
youngest black American playwright ever
on Broadway but ain't no mole class uh
close I should say less than a month
after opening CBS Saturday morning
co-host Michelle Miller met up with
Cooper at New York's crane theater where
the show debuted and they spoke about
why he believes this play had such a
short run despite critical success
are you riding High School I am I am in
Broadway's ain't no mo i
oh yeah that won't end well
Jordan e Cooper uses humor to spark
difficult conversations I always tell
people it's not gonna be easy for black
folks it's not gonna be easy for white
folks it's not gonna be easy for queer
folks but we all gonna sit here and
we're gonna have this conversation and
this experience together what about
those who say that that fear is
something African-Americans have always
had to overcome the play explores a
world where to end racism the U.S
government offers black Americans a
one-way ticket to Africa Miss bag will
be the carrier of our entire story as a
people in this country as we make this
glorious transition where did this idea
of this play come from I have a very
dark sense of humor so I have to find a
reason to laugh over the pain right
um and I remember how to run in with a
police officer at a 7-Eleven I remember
going back to my dorm room and just kind
of contemplating my own worth in a way
why do we go through this and why do we
put up with it
um and why don't we all just get on a
plane and leave and that's where a
normal came from
to be the first to welcome you to
African-American Airlines you're here
for it not just as writer but it's
peaches
yes the drag queen flight attendant in
charge of getting everyone on the plane
why drag queen because there's a very
interesting relationship between
Blackness and queerness and a lot of
times one wants you to pick the other uh
when in reality it's like they both
coexist at the same time I love the idea
of what if Blackness had to depend on
the blackest queerest person possible to
get them to their new leg of freedom
oscar-nominated director Lee Daniels
discovered Cooper while scouting for New
Riders and helped bring ain't no mo to
Broadway
he just kind of believed in it from the
very beginning he saw an early Workshop
of it and he came up to me in tears and
he was just like I have to make sure the
world sees this thing at 27 he became
the youngest black playwright in
Broadway history but despite strong
refuse ticket sales were poor and it was
announced ain't no mo which shut down
just over two weeks after opening a lot
of people just did not know about it you
know I made the mistake of thinking I
could just focus on the work being good
when I don't necessarily have that
privilege you know he says there has to
be a shift on Broadway for starters
marketing more to people of color I
think that theater is not accessible
people would tell me like oh black
people didn't get a chance to know your
show but also they don't go to Broadway
and I'm gonna tell you why a lot of
black folks do not go to Broadway
because we don't see ourselves we don't
see our name on the door but before it
closed stars like Tyler Perry and Queen
Latifah bought out full performances
hoping to keep the play alive when you
have like Heavy Hitters like that behind
you what did that say everybody who
poured into the show wanted to make a
point that this belongs on Broadway too
despite its short run ain't no mo earns
six Tony nominations including best
featured actor in a play for Cooper the
nominations were huge for me because
when I was in Texas with my family uh I
was grateful for that you leapt from the
couch
is the best play Arc
ain't no mother
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I did I really did that was a
moment that little Jordan has waited for
all his life his passion for performing
started at home and in the church in his
hometown of Hearst Texas
but New York City was always the goal
[Music]
city were you getting vibes from
it was here on the campus of the new
school where he wrote Ain't No moan what
would little Jordan 10 year old Jordan
be talking about
could you imagine this
did he imagine this he did imagine it he
did imagine it he didn't always know if
it was possible performing and riding
was a means of survival you know in the
sense of like
being once again queer in Black in the
South I knew I had to create and I had
to talk and I had to write in order to
really find my purpose in the world
and he found that Cooper says his only
regret after receiving the nods is that
he didn't get to go to the theater and
do a show the same night he's not only a
playwright he's also co-creator and
showrunner of the Miss Pat Show on BET
plus which was just renewed we have to
say for a fourth season and like CBS
News is a part of the Paramount Global
family yes knockout in it you can tell
how creative he is and it's it seems
like it closed just as it was starting
to build just just yeah performances and
I I have full disclosure I didn't even
get to see the play
thank you Michelle thank you thank you
Jordan we'll be right back